في الوقت الذي يخضع فيه الاعلامي الساخر
باسم يوسف للاستجواب بعد اصدار النيابه
المصريه امرا بضبطه بتهمه اهانه الرئيس
محمد مرسي والدين الاسلامي يرى الكثيرون
ان سقف حريه التعبير في البلاد بات في خطر
وخلال المقابله التي اجراها مع سي ان ان
اسر يوسف ا موقفه وتحديه
القر ساستمر في مواصله البرنامج وبنفس
النبره الم ولن اتراجع وستكون لدينا متعه
في العمل كالمعتاد
واستولت قضيه يوسف على الاهتمام الدولي
فكانت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه من بين
الذين اعربوا عن القلق ليس فقط حول قضيه
يوسف الى جانب اوامر القبض الصادره مؤخرا
بحق النشطاء السياسيين ما هي الا دليل على
وجود اتجاه مقلق من القيود المتزايده على
حريه التعبير ودافع الاعلامي الامريكي جون
ستيوارت عن يوسف خلال برنامجه الكوميدي
الشهير ذ ديلي
شو بدون باسم ومدونين وجميع الصحفيين
والمتظاهرين الشجعان الذين ذهبوا الىى
التحرير لما كنت يا رئيس مرسي في موقعك
لتق
مععهم قامت لاحقا السفاره الامريكيه
بالقاهره بنشر تغريده تتضمن وصله لبرنامج
ستيوارت الامر الذي ادى الى رد فعل سريع
من مكتب الرئاسه المصري فقال بدوره انه من
غير المناسب لبعثه دبلوماسيه المشاركه في
هذه الدعايه السياسيه السلبيه لكن جماعات
حقوق الانسان تقول ان الاجراءات التي
اتخذتها السلطات المصريه غير مناسبه
وتخالف ما قاله الرئيس مرسي في
السابق اعتقد ان هناك نيه واضحه من جانب
الرئيس مرسي وحزب الحريه والعداله الحاكم
للحد من حريه التعبير والاعلام الحر فاذا
كان الرئيس مرسي يريد وقف هذه الاجراءات
الصارمه على وسائل الاعلام نستطيع ان نرى
ذلك غدا ان حزبه حزب الحريه والعداله
يسيطر على السلطه التشريعيه ويمكنه تعديل
قانون العقوبات وعدم تجريم
التشهير